so uh i guess i want to start with the
most important question right up front
um is today during this interview the
moment where you want to talk about a
possible spin-off or
solo or anything that will keep this uh
thing going uh because you know why not
no one's recording anything
well if it's just between us
it's that uh you know there's three more
books
um there's a lot more story to tell
and it's a very big world lots of stuff
can happen here and we all love working
together
you know there's a lot of uh structural
positives
anything could happen
well the reason i ask this is that um
i've seen all of season six i'm not
gonna spoil anything uh obviously but um
you do include something uh that is sort
of like i don't want to call it like the
better call saul but like there's a
little there's stuff in this in season
six that sort of teases what can be or
what might like i don't know how to say
that yeah
um
you know what i mean i
exactly you know exactly what you mean
the reason we put the strange dogs
novella in the season was a couple of
things it was
partially because there's a big mystery
at the end of season five as to what's
happening with the protomolecule sample
what you know what's going on in this
planet of laconia with the protomolecule
scientist what happens to the ship that
disappears all of these elements are in
the world if we hadn't touched on it in
some fashion it would have been like i
think a big gaping hole in the season
and unsatisfying because the
proto-molecule was such a big part of
the motor that has driven much of the
expanse um and yes it does open up a
door and it does give you a glimpse of
maybe things that are coming down the
road it is absolutely intentional um but
it does service the story in season six
and that was really the primary element
of it
uh the season is six episodes and i'm
curious
did you guys decide on the six episodes
because of like a budgetary thing was it
what amazon said what is it you guys
said i think it's going to be six
episodes like how did that decision get
worked out that is way above our pay
grade so far
yeah as noreen pointed out uh earlier um
that is a studio and network
conversation uh
they come to us as the writers and say
here's how many you have we don't we
don't get to give feedback on that yeah
the the way it was brought to us really
was because we had always our minimum
was ten episodes up until this point and
so for a lot of factors um i'm sure
budget was one of them i'm sure time in
terms of time to getting the shows back
on the air and production and everything
else
they came to us and said can you tell
the story of season six in six episodes
and you know we had probably mentally in
our minds we would probably thought ten
episodes really be ideal um or we just
got used to that pattern so it did
require some thought i mean it did
require like you know how what are we
going to keep in what are we going to
you know have to like kind of go by the
wayside but um i i think we're i think
at the end of the day i think we're
happy with the way this turned out it's
a good compressed consistently tense run
through the season and it keeps building
and that's actually i think a really
good thing oh 100 and the other thing is
that like in all seriousness i'm so
thankful for them putting this on the
air that if they had said you need to do
it in a two-hour movie i would have said
yeah that sounds great
but whatever you know what i mean i'm
just so thankful that you guys got to
tell a final season you know what i mean
no no no
there were there were times in previous
seasons where people would come and say
do you think there's a way you could
kind of just
kind of pull it all together at the end
of this season and just make a
satisfying ending right here and we were
like no no
yeah no no that can't happen that's not
a thing
i mean there were two times where we
felt like we could uh we felt like we
could deliver uh uh season three
yeah had a lot of had a lot of
possibility for new stories but felt
satisfying uh no unsatisfying yeah
and then season six is the other place
so those are the two places where
you can you can kind of off ramp off the
store
what do you guys think it is i mean i'm
obviously a big fan and there's a lot of
very passionate fans out there what do
you actually think it is about the
expanse that has pulled that is you know
um
uh by someone i'm looking for the right
word but why so many people have
responded to it and are so passionate
about it um
i want to tell this story about season
one really quick um because i think this
this is the answer um
they did uh they did one of those word
cloud things where where they they
pulled a bunch of people who had watched
the first uh 10 episodes the first
season and asked them what does this
most remind you of and then the words
would be the size depending on how many
people said that thing and there was a
few battlestar galactica's there was a
few star treks and there was you know
and they were kind of small the biggest
word on there by far was nothing
um people watched it and they hadn't
ever seen anything like it before and i
think really that's our strength that's
that that's the thing that keeps the
fans passionate is you you when we're
not around there's a not another thing
you easily slot in to replace us because
there's nothing else really like us
that's true for the show for the show
that's true for the show i think i think
weirdly it's exactly the other way for
the books
i think the books we went into um
having
you know we both grew up on 70 science
fiction we both grew up on bester and
clark and uh heinlein and um and some of
those have aged really well and some of
them have not um
and
a lot of what we were doing with
the books was trying to take the spirit
that we loved
from those books when we were kids and
remaking them in a way that that's
accessible to people now and accessible
to us now
um
in the way that the the old stuff
sometimes didn't work
i obviously could uh i don't know how
much you guys want to say about season
six so i'll just say for the fans um
what are you what do you want to tease
people about season six
tease people let's see no i'm not gonna
tease i'm gonna see i'm gonna say um
the the
uh
the ending is
good
i'm gonna say the ending is good we got
to we got to the ending we wanted i'm
satisfied with how it happened um i've
heard a lot of
uh panicky responses around the number
six and the end of a season of a
long-running show and people imagining
the worst and i just want to say it's
gonna be all right it's gonna be okay
yeah i'll let go i've seen episode six
um people people are going to be okay
i mean like you don't you don't have to
worry but
that actually leads me to um i do want
to talk about episode 6 not in specifics
though but how tough was it to actually
write that episode in comparison to all
the others because you know this is the
final chapter this is where you kind of
have to tie loose strings together and
and also how much do you want to set you
know what i mean everything that goes
into a finale um
it's a tremendous amount of care and
effort and it was actually
complicated by the fact that we shot
episode one and episode six at the very
beginning of the season yeah breck
eisner did the blocks so we actually
shot the beginning and the end
simultaneously so that script had to get
done right you know and so um we had
written drafts of all the other episodes
but they weren't finished finished but
episode six had to be finished at the
very beginning um and so you don't want
to get it wrong you don't want to get it
wrong after five seasons of a show and
and finish the six on a bad note and so
that was a tremendous amount of
of effort on the writing side the
production side everything it was um
that was a big hurdle to get over i
would say we had an advantage this
season in the writing that we didn't
have in the earlier seasons which is um
the core team the core writing team had
been working together for six years at
that point
and
every episode is always a team effort
from the writers room but more than any
other season these were really team
written scripts
it was it was
such a great collective effort because
everybody really was committed to the
idea of of
doing justice to the characters that had
been in the show for this length of time
and that was really the overriding thing
we we really we slaved over those
yeah there was some work yeah well and
nobody brought their ego to it because
it's if if some it didn't matter if your
name was on a script or not if somebody
asked you to take a pass or to write a
section you just did it because it was
it was about the team and that's always
you know that that's sort of the the
nature of television i mean you know
this is this is what people will tell
you about working on television shows
but it is a deeply collaborative process
and um it was really a fun season it was
actually it was actually a blast even
though we had to be remote and we
couldn't spend enough time together um
it was really fun
i don't want to say how long it is but
the last episode is the longest of the
season with this being with this being
streaming um can you sort of talk about
did you end up having like a longer cut
of that episode how does it work in
terms of um like deleted scenes and
stuff i'm i'm sort of curious i'm i'm
not a big believer in deleted scenes
because that usually means we've done
our job wrong um but on the on the story
side um that episode was designed to be
a big episode it was designed to be uh
it's like almost 65 minutes long it was
designed to be that way we knew it was
going to be about an episode and a half
and it's written accordingly um
um yeah so that was part of the plan and
we were also kind of like we wanted to
kind of go out with a bang
but but in in the spirit of deleted
scenes there is something um there's the
this season there's a a series of five
x-ray extras the the little uh there
there's five little vignettes between
the episodes that um weren't
things that we cut out of these scripts
these are just declared absolutely these
are not deleted scenes these are
specific one kind of one-act little
character plays at the ends of the
episodes that illuminate the episodes
and there are there are five of them um
and they came together really well yeah
i was really impressed by how that
worked out yeah i i did not know this
was coming and so i know i still have
stuff to watch that is great
you do they're going to pop up at the
end of the episode um and uh so you yeah
like when the episode's over you do a
pause and the x-ray thing will come up
and that's how you'll access them
uh again without getting into spoilers
how much did you debate that the final
shot of episode six did you always know
what that shot was going to be oh yeah
yeah it was it was it's written
on the page the way it is written is the
way it looks
yeah yeah almost exactly too am i
remembering i did
daniel pitched that oh yeah no i i i've
been fighting for that one since the
beginning yeah yeah
no that was i that that was the ending i
wanted
i've never been on any of the sets uh
and so i am curious if you could have if
you could have kept something like one
of the sets from the expanse in like
your backyard you know or some location
near where you live which is the one set
you would have wanted to keep and why
the rossi yeah now you got to keep the
rossi cutting the the bridge of the
roster yeah it's awesome it's got you
know it's got the bunk bed thing going
on there's lots of places you can hurt
yourself lots of places you can hurt
yourself
blood all of the
i feel like that's one of those sets
that people will be able to identify
readily years from now
like when they see the rossi ops deck i
think they'll they'll i think people
will understand that did you on the last
day of filming though um like go into
the set and sort of just like rip out
chairs and say this is coming home with
me no we we didn't get to go on set this
year because
all we could do is like
look at it from our ipads and
zoom connections
yeah that i'm not a fan of that i need
you guys to be able to keep some stuff
oh i still i stole a lot of props but
that's what i mean yeah like i had the
dedication plaque the original yeah
exactly i mean if anyone's going to get
stuff it needs to be you guys yeah i
think so yeah
[Laughter]
i don't know who's going to get mad at
you um you know what i mean if you're
like borrow anyway what are they going
to
play
us
we're good
you know
so uh for
i am curious though when you're right
which characters ended up being the
toughest to write for uh and why were
there certain like or certain story
lines that ended up being like
you know like more struggling with
holden is always the hardest character
to write always because he has the
longest
arc
of character development across the six
seasons
and
makes
often makes choices that are not easy to
understand on first viewing
and you don't want your audience
confused you want people to think he's
just randomly deciding things you want
the audience to feel like they
eventually understand why he does the
things that he does
that's that requires some some subtlety
it's it's it's a hard it's a hard
character to get right yeah i think
steven got a lot of uh static he didn't
deserve in the first few seasons for
what was actually a pretty good
portrayal of who holden was at that
point yeah um and i hope that the where
holden ends up
here
makes those choices
clearer and more justified
better what what stephen was up to yeah
oh i got um i gotta i'm already getting
the signal i'm just gonna say that man i
really love this series thank you so
much for making it and thank you for
giving me your time
thank you this is really fun
thank you and go steal some more [ __ ]
from set
copy
you